à berlin une petite baraque en
préfabriqué était devenu l'un des
symboles de la guerre froide le
checkpoint charlie a disparu aujourd'hui
22 juin 1990 il y a trente ans le poste
frontière checkpoint charlie qu à berlin
étaient démantelés depuis sa mise en
place en août 1961 en même temps que le
mur de berlin il était le symbole de la
guerre froide qui pouvait devenir
brûlant à cet endroit dès la première
année de son installation
les troupes ont été mises en état d'
alerte et de chaque côté de la frontière
chars américains et chars soviétiques se
sont fait face au point de passage de la
friedrichstrasse pendant près de 12
heures
chaque fois ils charlie c'était le lieu
de passage de plus médiatisé du mur
réservé aux diplomates aux étrangers ce
poste frontière représenter la
séparation entre deux mondes deux
sociétés allemagne de l'est soviétique
d'un côté allemagne de l'ouest
capitaliste soutenu par les américains
de l'autre cette guérite devient le lieu
de passage incontournable pour les
présidents américains en visite pour les
journalistes c'est l'endroit où
physiquement on voit la séparation tout
proche du mur idéal pour les duplex
on retrouve maintenant patrick lecocq à
checkpoint charlie à dire en direct de
berlin pour la suite de cette antenne
2010 patrick en direct sur antenne 2 en
le journaliste va au plus près de la
frontière si on voulait aller par là on
va jusqu'où la votre avis
je crois qu'on peut rester là mais on
est photographié pour la vie en ce
moment et la prochaine fois que l'on
aura envie de passer à l'est on n'aura
pas de problème mais on attendra un
petit peu plus longtemps que d'habitude
mais tout va changer le 9 novembre 1989
avec la chute du mur le poste frontière
ouvre ses barrières et vous entendez ces
cris on salue ainsi l'arrivée des
voitures qui continuent de venir de père
laisse les petites trappes hantz est
toute petite voiture on tape dessus on a
l'impression qu'elles vont se casser en
miettes
on passe les bouteilles de champagne il
ya des feux de bengale les gardes qui
ont contrôlé cette frontière depuis 1961
sont dépassés et on finit par oublier
que la derrière il y a encore des
miradors et déjà policiers etc vos pots
qui pendant des années ont fait peur et
qui ont tué quelques mois après le 22
juin 1990 la guérite et transporté au
musée du mur aujourd'hui sur la
friedrichstrasse eux le mur a disparu
mais la guérite a été reconstitué c'est
devenu une attraction pour les touristes
où il faut payer pour se faire prendre
en photo
[Musique]